these comments that flow into things I
think it was actually was one of your
clips and somebody somebody down there
was saying I hate plot you know I want
story and that poor person obviously is
not educated about these things because
plot and story are the same bloody thing
they are a story is plot plot is story
maybe we can get there in a minute or
two but make those mistakes and that's
just that's just ignorance you know and
you can get educated and you can learn
the tools and how to use them it is to
be out there so I'm going to create this
beautiful big intricate thing and not
know the pieces of it it's like going to
say I'm going to create this big
beautiful house and I know absolutely
nothing about cement electrical cabling
roofing shingles glass or you got to
know all these things before you can
build a house and I believe the same is
true for really good screenwriting for
empowerment I'll throw out some some of
the silly stuff but useful useful stuff
did you know for instance there are only
four viable goals in all of narrative
screenwriting and the vocals are yeah
when stop escape or retrieve so oK
you've got an idea for a character your
hero or heroine great you've got an idea
and they have okay now what is it that
you want what they've got to have a goal
to pursue right well it has to fall into
the category of wins doth escape or
retrieve now these are big categories
and there are many versions of each
woman many permutations of each one so
it's not like it's that cut and dried
but it will appear to a lot of people
like it's that's to cut and dried for me
but the point is this there's only those
four because those four share something
in common they all provide a visible
physical 3-dimensional goal for a motion
picture that
result in a physical climax and
obligatory scene it precludes the use of
internal golds and that's one of the
things people have to get over an
internal goal that's great and it is
separate from what drives the movie you
need a physical visible goal each one of
those four goals has a finish line a
visible finish line and a goal like well
they want to feel better about
themselves that doesn't work on film it
just doesn't work and that there are
only four emotions mad sad glad and
scared you haven't heard that one yeah
again there are they they are you know
there's a lot of variations with Mann's
meds Ed glad and scared there's many
permutations and and dimensions there
but the way they are useful is like this
if you are building if you're outlining
something a section a particular section
here a goal sequence or a particular
scene the thing is the way you guarantee
that it's going to have conflict and
change in it and change is one of the
single most important is to talk about
that in a minute to change is the power
that makes screenplays either work or
not work
you got to quantify it but it can be
done wonderfully that if if the hero
lead character walks stomps jumps falls
into a scene and they are either mad sad
glad or scared by the end of the scene
they have to be one of the others if
they're mad when they show up they have
to be scared when they walk away or if
they're scared when they show up they
have to be glad when they walk away
because that guarantees dramatic change
within the scene and it's a way of
checking yourself because we read a
whole lot of scenes which are just talk
and they're the same everything is the
same at the end as as it was at the
beginning and that is not a viable scene
for visual story
things like that you know there are only
fourteen character categories in all of
dramatic writing and all of narrative
writing you have to know the 14
categories and you have to know how they
work and how they interrelate the puzzle
pieces to create plot how they advance
how they can advance a story I'm just
curious what sorry to interrupt but what
are the what are a few of the 14 just
for instance the other words let me
qualify there are 14 character Gadar
character categories that advance and
serve story story is a central character
hero or heroine who undertakes to do
something physically do something in
order to achieve a visible physical goal
by the end kind of stuff and in that
pursuit there are 14 other character
categories who serve as either helpers
or hinder vers toward that hero and they
are mean like first of all when in main
categories are our hero and adversary
who adversary is much unsung and under
under appreciated the adversary is
critical and and the point
I mean without without conflict you
don't have a story there is no story
without conflict that's it you know so
that adversary is key to the creating of
conflict and so it puts a lot of weight
on who the adversary is so you got hero
adversary then there is a mentor a very
wide and delicious category and you know
goes back to Joe Campbell and and the
assessment of the mythological approach
stuff that there's some of those
characters I mean he called the
adversary the shapeshifter that's some
more specific usage yes it's adversary
shapeshifter is is somebody who appears
one thing on the outside and become
something else that is one kind of
adversary but not the only kind so and
then there's mentor there's the love
interest character this is interesting
love interest character I really go into
this and do
details or folks for some I mean the
love interest character brings depth and
humanity and and and helps augments and
eases character growth forward for the
central character and it is the least
used character category of all the grad
students who pass through here
interesting yeah it really is I think
it's the character it gets too close to
home maybe their experience you know in
these things emotional sensual
experience is highly limited or
something what it is something about it
but that is a key character and stories
that work and you have a romance subplot
that love interest character well when
it's done well it's one of the most
powerful things you can add to a story
and then there are helper follower
allies and and a sidekick sidekick is
another category very specific function
is played by the sidekick and and others
there is the adversary agent see there
is one adversary adversary can only be
one one person human being or a
personified thing a monster that behaves
like a human being and things like a
human being but the one thing one human
being but they can also have all kinds
of adversary agents running around doing
the bidding of the adversary so in let's
say Erin Brokovich they're fighting this
like toxic tort or whatever anything and
and so the the workers of the plant or
of the you know are sort of the
adversary agent because they're maybe
not the ones totally calling the shots
but they're working for the people that
are calling the shot yes okay except for
the ones that turn to the good side you
know who jump over to the good people
and and then there's a group of
characters called gate Guardians and
that's I would put those people in the
gate Guardian category gate Guardian is
a character who this business from
and the mythological structure to gate
gaurdian is a character who when first
met by the hero when first confronted by
the hero stops them says no you cannot
enter here but once the hero finds a way
to outsmart that gate guarding it's
never brute force it's brilliant when
they outsmart them and find a way to get
around them and continue their journey
after that the gate guardian becomes an
ally interesting at first opposes and
then assists and I and a few wanted
Seymour in there too but see but the
point is all of these characters there's
only 14 that that help you create a plot
that help move a story forward and any
other character that the particular
writer wants to plot you know I really
like this character you know they're
kind of interesting and peppy and zippy
and they talk funny and I like it if
they do not serve the story if they do
not help drive the plot forward get
rhythm axel cut them lose them because
they have to serve a function
you